as chair of the house ways and means
committee i find that due to the state
of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covert 19
pandemic and in accordance with house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a full committee work session
executive sessions on pending
legislation may be held
please note there is no physical
location for the public to observe
and listen contemporariously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order and confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
contemporariously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general website the notice
for this meeting complies with the house
rules of rsa
91-8 anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 271
or email hcs leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that a
meeting insisting that
assisting us jennifer floor and the
committee research
who is the committee researcher
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of attendance
when each member states their presence
please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room
which is required under the right to
i'll rule thank you mr chair
and uh i think we'll all be impressed
representative abrami here home alone
stratum
representative griffin yes
here here in my home alone
soon as i find the unmute button i'll
say that i'm here in my office alone
thank you representative ober erin
hudson with six cats
doucet here in my home office salem
alone
burst dean is here in nottingham in his
home office alone
elliot here and my wife is in the
kitchen
here in my home office in salem new
hampshire my wife and daughter are
somewhere in the house
nunes good morning representative thank
you i'm home alone in hellham
baxter
he's running a couple of minutes late
okay uh
representative spillsberg you're alone
in charlestown at home tudor
you'll be on in just a moment
okay thank you ames yeah here alone and
jeffrey in my home office
southworth here home alone in dover
malloy here in greenland
and uh my wife is in the house
jamberg i'm in my truck coming back from
concord to wilmette
alone tucker i'm
alone in randolph go marlow
malone and swansea laughman
home alone in hampton good morning
representative gorg good morning i am
alone
back in phillips morning i'm present
from my office in concord
alone murphy
good morning i'm here alone in my office
in hanover
representative major here i'm in my
office in blasto and my wife is in the
house
thank you representative i'm here and
alum
and representative almighty
thank you uh sorry that i lost my link
i'm here alone in my house in lebanon
mr chair i'm happy to have your 100
attendance
okay today is a work session on the
house bills that we previously heard
on the 28th of january and the 4th
communicated them have had their caucus
republicans have had their caucus we
review the bills
both caucuses are in agreement with
representative and myself have been
meeting after the caucus meeting
to compare notes and what i'd like to be
able to do
is concentrate on those bills
that we are in agreement on first
and get those uh discuss and
exact and then we can continue
the rest of the day on those that
uh we need more work are very
controversial
that
house bill 354
these should not be discussed and
exactly
well let me know i don't see any hands
house bill 134 repealing certain
inactive
dedicated funds does anybody have any
it was a great job done by the uh joint
committee
if not do i hear a motion
on house bill 134
yes representative bershteen will move
this should
otp h.b 134.
representative bernstein moves over to p
on 134
right here or second i would like to
second it
represent only seconds the motion
we are now in an executive section not
sure mention that for us
um any further discussion
then i'll ask the clerk to call the vote
if you're in favor of ought to pass on
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote on hb 134 the motion is ought
to pass
griffin
star six she's not she can't vote
because she doesn't have a camera
right okay she knows that she's aware of
that
okay representative hollery yes
ober yes the clerk votes yes
do set yes
elliot
representative elliot okay
did you hear me no
yes thank you representative jeanine
yes nunez
yes baxter yes
spillsbury yes tudor
yes aomi yes
ames yes southward
yes malloy yes schaumburg
yes tucker yes go marlo
yes schaumburg is he on video
oh let's back up uh yes i was
yeah okay yes okay and
uh representative laughman i'm not
seeing you
there you go okay thank you
representative gorg yes haken phillips
yes murphy yes
and representative major yes
devoted 23 to nothing with one no vote
one not voting
does anybody have objections to having
and no objection then
the emotion about to pass passes
and it will appear on the consent
calendar
representative major may i have a may i
say something
yes um it's it's easy if you have a
laptop
or a desktop to just hit the space bar
and say yes or no
and then you don't to go through the the
mouse
maneuvering just a hint but i've
discovered you have to hit it in the
middle
anything
hospital 181 relative to the local
option for
operation sports retail locations
mr chairman yes i i just like to say
something brief about it the prime
sponsor
had has not communicated with us at all
and it looks very much like the bill on
it was brought in meant to be brought in
last year and that it's really not
necessary at this point
so do i hear a motion to itl
from somebody in your caucus and we'll
back it up by
marcos um i don't know if anybody i'll
i'll do it okay resident element
makes the motion of itl on hospital 181
and representing early second the second
bit
going to executive session oops
i screwed up again but that's all right
we are now in an executive session on
house bill 181
representative made the motion of itl
second by representing early
saying none i'll ask the court to call
the rules thank you mr chair the motion
is itl
on hb 181 let's begin the roll call vote
with representative abrami
yes representative griffin will not be
voting
representative overreally yes
oh wait he's got to show his face yes
thank you ober yes
the clerk berstein votes yes doucet
yes elliot yes genigean
yes nunes yeah
show his face he was off sorry
yup there he is hey
baxter yes
paul you're muted right now you stopped
put your video on and unmute there you
go
sorry my uh my internet's flipping out
here but yes
yes representative ames yes
southward yes malloy yes
schaumburg yes tucker
laughman yes
gorg yes
hacking phillips yes murphy
yes major yes
mr chair of the vote is 23 to nothing
with one member not voting
for the vote 23 to nothing motion passes
without objection it will go on consent
calendar
in the objection
then it will appear on the consensus
uh representative major
yes this is uh representative ames
yes representations i just have a
question and a suggestion with regard to
representative griffin who's apparently
unable to
use video and whether it might be by
consensus of the committee
allowed for her to vote we all recognize
her voice
so we have recognition there and uh
as an exception to the rule that uh
you're properly enforcing in all other
respects
i had that discussion uh with
but you've got to be able to see the
person
i i agree with you representations
and i try to make that happen
well thank you for that and i regret
that
we're in this situation it's it's most
unfortunate
it certainly is i tried as well
representative major
couldn't make the chairs meeting on
monday i brought that up as well
uh to the speaker and uh
he took it under consideration but i
think as representative major said
it was he had wanted to start making
exceptions and i used the same argument
you did
we all recognize her and i suggested it
if
if all the members of the committee
agreed it was something that we should
allow but
you know didn't go anywhere i agree with
you too dick
thank you mary here is important to
us as anybody else's so
that's just that's what the rule is
okay
324.
house bill 324 relative to the
administration of certain state taxes by
the department of revenue administration
this is a housekeeping bill
making the motion so this is a reminder
it does four things
clarifies electronic following emails
rooms taxes excel
excludes interest for the 30-day period
after notice of assessment of state
taxes
for amounts paid within 30 day period
removes the
consideration of weighted apportionment
factors under the business profits tax
from exclusion in the tax exemption
report
and the fourth thing it does is it
provides for conformity and business tax
filing dates
on nonprofit corporations and in this
state with the united states internal
revenue code filing dates
and we really didn't have much
discussion about this or
uh when we heard the bill presented by
dra
so i think we're ready to go
so representative we're going to
executive session representative
bromley you making the motion yeah i'm
making the motion
otp representative southworth second
i really can't hear representative
abrami very well
i'm trying any better
okay the motion has been made by
representative obama
lots of past seconds by representing
southwest
and then i'm going to ask the clerk to
call the
vote thank you mr chair let's begin the
roll call vote with representative
abrami
yes mary griffin will not be voting
turn on your uh video and unmute
yourself
jordan yes
thank you representative ober yes
clerk berstein votes yes ducette
yes elliot yes
yes nunes yes
baxter yes spillsberry
is it susan i know the space bar didn't
work for a minute
on yes thank you for the space bar to
work
the zoom window has to be your active
window if you're
working in another window the zoom the
uh space bar will not work
i was raising the volume representative
ames
yes southworth yes
malloy yes schomburg
representative schambach votes yes
thank you representative tucker yes
go marlo yes laughman
yes i see you gorg
yes hacking phillips
okay mr chair the motion of ought to
pass
passes 23 to nothing with one member not
voting
on house bill 324 the motion about to
pass
passes by voter 23 to zero without
objection we'll go on the consent
calendar
i don't see any objections so it will go
on the consent calendar
thank you house bill 354 and act
relative to the local option for sports
betting
so
may i suggest that when the clerk begins
to call the role
time
just move things along
as long as one person doesn't keep
saying yes
okay well all right
on husband 54 yeah
uh yes i do house bill 354 is about the
problem of
liability the present wording says
we are liable
but that term is not very clear as to
who we
is the new wording is an attempt to make
it perfectly clear
that the town or city is the liable
entity so in the case of my hometown
salem new hampshire
the word will be quite definite and i
quote
shall the town of salem new hampshire
allow the operation of
sportsbook retail locations within the
town of salem new hampshire
period thus making the town liable
not we thank you mr chairman
do i hear a motion
i shall move oh i can't i close you
can yes you can i moved
and we have somebody from the other
caucus that would want to
okay the motion on hospital 354 is ought
to pass by representative elliot
seconded by representative murphy any
discussion
saying no discussion i'll ask the clerk
to call the vote
thank you mr chair it's a roll call vote
on hb
354 uh consider unmuting yourself right
now and let's blow through this and make
representative tucker
proud of our committee let's begin the
vote with representative abrami
yes representative griffin will not be
voting
uh hold on
representative overy yeah elbert
yes jerk votes yes doucet
yes elliot yes
yes nunes yes baxter
yes gillsbury yes tudor
yes army yes
ames yes southworth
yes malloy yes jamberg
representative schamberg voces tucker
yes go marlo yes laughman
yes gorg yes hacken phillips
yes murphy yes major
yes great job everyone the vote is
he's smiling okay house bill
the vote on house bill uh 354
about to pass passes the vote of 23 to
zero
without objection go on the consent
calendar
i don't see it so go on the consent
mr chair i'd like to make a motion to
itl
uh hb528 okay uh
just one second i'm gonna pull it out
and hospital 528 is an act relative to
electronic filing of state tax returns
and representative baxter made a motion
of itl i'd like to second that
okay
so you have to wait up for my
it can't be worse than mine mr chair
oh you haven't seen mine we do have a
murphy oh mercy
that's kind of a little blow suit i
write pretty well
my parents were doctored i was taught by
the jesuits to write well they will take
you a while too
they use the ruler if it doesn't write
well or write good
jesuits all right
um on house bill 528 motion has been
made to itl by representative baxter
seconded by representative tucker any
discussion
on this
now i'm going to ask the clerk to call
the rules
thank you mr chair let's begin the roll
call vote on hb
528 the motion is itl
let's begin with representative abrami
yes
representative griffin is not voting
representative ollary
yes representative ober yes
13 votes yes ducette yes
elliot yes
yes nunes yes baxter
tudor
uh we didn't hear your representative
yes i'm still having trouble with
internet here
it was yes very good thank you
representative
yes ames yes southworth
yes lloyd yes john berg
representative schamberg vote yes tucker
yes laughman yes
sorry go marlo yes
gord yes hacking phillips
yes murphy yes
representative major yes
mr chair the vote is 23 to love with one
member not voting
the vote of itl on house bill 528
bin 23 0
passes without objection it will appear
on
i see no objection so it will appear on
which is a truly uh
and but we're not going to take a vote
on it today
we'll vote on it tomorrow so
hp 10 and act relative to the rates of
business profits tax and business
and this reduces the business profits
tax from 0.7.7
to 7.5 over two years
and the business enterprise tax goes
from
point zero six percent
to point zero five percent over two
years
thank you mr chairman i oppose uh
the further cutting of state-level
business taxes
i think there's still too many unknown
factors that can affect
the revenue projections um now how long
will it take to move beyond
the many impacts of the covid pandemic
uh the timeline for public vaccination
changes regularly
some people are not following safety
recommendations
some people won't get vaccinated once
new hampshire does make significant
progress
against covid it's still unclear how the
new hampshire economy will rebound
the business tax picture is further
complicated by the upcoming shift to
market-based sourcing
and the future use of the single sales
factors
with all the above questions still
unanswered it seems prudent to maintain
the current business tax percentages
for the next biennium thank you
thank you representative southwest
representative thank you mr chairman
on we we really don't have
any idea yet what the next 12 months and
the next budget
is our term is going to bring
on there are the medical community
thinks that the variance
on that we're going to end up in a race
with the variants to get enough people
vaccinated
so that they will not be mutating and
spreading
all over the country they are spreading
in other parts of the world
at this point and that has a huge
effect on our economy and when we can
start to come
out of the coved era on
both market-based sourcing and the
single sales factor
our current law on we're going to have
to
take a wild stab at what they do when we
do our revenue estimates
that goes to the budget the budget is
then going to add
this i presume on end
and we we will have an extremely
risky on balance between
expenditures and revenues
when we get there uh
at the bia summit this fall business
ceos revealed that they are told by
their accountants
only what their total tax burden is not
how much of it
is federal taxes state taxes municipal
property
taxes water district taxes or whatever
it is also not near the top of their
list of priorities
in fact on average in 2019 slightly over
half of their state and local
tax and fee burden was property tax and
less than a quarter of it was our
business taxes
the property tax share has been growing
over the years
as we cut state business taxes and
shifted the cost to the
towns our largest state level
revenue source is paid overwhelmingly by
multi-state and multinational
corporations
that regard new hampshire's taxes as
very low on their
list of reasons to operate here there
are well over half
of the state's businesses that have no
tax liability at all
for the business taxes and an unknowable
number of them do not even file
uh so you're aiming this tax
decrease at businesses that really
aren't paying attention
to it on and further reduction of those
business taxes
is counterproductive both to our economy
and to our citizenry
because of this shift somebody has to
pay
for the state government and for the
town governments
and we are sending more and more of that
burden down to the town governments
thank you thank you representative
representative romney yeah thank you
mr chair um yeah this brings us back to
the house position of a couple of years
ago
as you know that in the last budget uh
the compromise
was triggers six percent i think it was
six percent either way
on on general and education fund
revenues
if if they fell below six percent then
we would revert
back an increment from what had already
been happened reduction would have
been uh we had to go back a step and
uh but the other six percent the other
way was we could continue with
the tax reductions if uh revenues
exceeded
that revenue from education and the
general
trust fund money uh and
neither those triggers were hit so the
the the continuation of the tax
reduction
stopped this bill just moves uh
forward again um and
as far as the uh pandemic
uh it's we won't know until april
uh march and april where we really stand
with business taxes
but all indications are that since we
have so many large companies
that make up the triangle there uh
and they seem to have weathered so far
it seems like they're weathering
the pandemic quite well i'm a little bit
more optimistic about where
our business taxes will come in uh at
the end of it by the end of this year
and going forward
those are my comments thank you thank
you representative
romney representative murphy
oh thank you mr chairman um
i i think that you know speaking from
the medical community
covid just like the the great recession
has had obviously devastating
consequences we've had over we will have
over 500 000 dead
in the country in the economic downturn
has been significant so
i know we have been trying to get a hold
of
authorities so to speak that can speak
to the impact of covet going forward
we have not been successful so i've
infectious disease and epidemiologists
that i know well
and their opinion about the near-term
future especially in the first year of
our biennium
is that it's not predictable at all
they're very
positive about the vaccines and its
effectiveness they're very positive
about the fact that 85 percent of the
country is now
wearing masks but we know that the
variance
in the vaccine effectiveness against
these variants is
unpredictable and not as good there was
a recent article just yesterday in the
valley news up here
in the ap speaking to the fact that
people that have had previous infections
are not really certain to be immune
going forward
or they may not have the same immunity
as a vaccine provides so
in that regard i would like to draw your
attention to
a article that came out just two days
ago from the fiscal policy institute
i think we know phil slatten well we
know that he is fairly unbiased
and it's apropos to our discussions
today it's titled actually and i can
send it to everybody if they want it
designing a state budget to meet the new
hampshire needs during and after covet
19.
how appropriate is that and what their
research
shows is that during and after the great
recession
moody's analytics in the congressional
budget office
both looked hard at the
economic or the policies that actually
stimulate or do not stimulate economic
growth
the research suggested that deploying
research
resources first to low income into
public services
goes a lot further in stimulating
economic activity so for instance they
gave specific numbers
for every dollar in expenditures that
they looked at after the great recession
the snap program supplemental nutrition
returned on an investment of 1.75
basically
uh 75 percent over the dollar invested
unemployment insurance benefits
about 60. public health infrastructure
a buck 60. child tax credits
about 40. these are all improvements or
these are all
measured in economic activity when they
looked at corporate and business income
tax
reductions the return on one dollar was
0.3
30 cents on a dollar that does not seem
good
i would just argue that given the
uncertainty going forward especially in
the first year of a
biennium where we may have some
flexibility
we can debate in the future whether or
not you know the merits of decreased
taxes are appropriate for corporate and
businesses
however i think now in the middle of a
pandemic
an uncertain future and given the
research
in the experience from the great
recession this is just not the time
to be cutting corporate or business
taxes and it's supported by research
not in new hampshire but by the
congressional budget office in moody's
analytics so thank you very much for
listening
well thank you representative
why don't you go ahead and email that to
us
i will email you and sue so she can just
you guys can
send it out on the list service how's
that sound okay thank you
baxter
thank you mr chair um obviously we are
coming out of the pandemic
you know a lot of the briefings we're
seeing it appears that
we might be turning this corner but
there's still some uncertainty and i
think especially because of that
uncertainty
is why we should be prioritizing um
these these tax cuts and really it's a
return to the already existing schedule
so there's nothing that dramatic here
but
95 or more uh 96
by some estimates of the employers in
new hampshire are small businesses
you know these these mom-and-pop
businesses have been decimated during
cobit
and this gradual reduction in the the
business uh profit tax and the vet
uh are very important to helping small
businesses survive and turn the cor
to turn the corner a lot of small
businesses are struggling they've racked
up debt
they're on the brink of closing and so
these these tax cuts on the margin can
help keep
our small businesses alive and it's done
in a very responsible way
um it's gradual and as pat pointed out
the trigger still exists so if revenue
does drop off
um you know things will revert but i
strongly support
uh these tax cuts thank you mr chair
uh
we ought to change uh representative
ames
thank you um
a couple of preliminaries representative
baxter just said there
the trigger still exists so far as i
know it does not
i think uh it does not either
it's past history right so that needs to
be clear
and the second preliminary point is that
i just sent
to all members this early this morning
a letter to andrew klein
responding to a letter that he sent to
all of us
in which he referred to an article and
sent
well he sent us a link to an article
that was published by one of the federal
reserve branches
and it's a staff working article and the
letter that i
sent points out that within that article
there are caveats that essentially make
it inapplicable to
the situation we have here in new
hampshire
and i also drew attention to
another article a more recent article
um that comes to quite a different
conclusion the the matter addressed in
these articles
is entrepreneurial activity particularly
startup
activity and the
second article says that there's no
evidence one way or the other as to the
impact of
the kinds of stack of tax changes we're
talking about it
here in the context of of uh
house bill 10. so that's preliminary and
then
make a more in-depth
statement and point about
the assertions responding to the
assertions by supporters of this bill
that business tax revenues will go up
when rates go down
i find that these assertions are backed
only by
anecdote and ideology or sometimes by
graphs
that display apparent historical
correlations
between increased revenues and tax
rate reductions particularly pointing to
this last
decade of experience that we've had here
in new hampshire
i suggest that these assertions are
are not supported by a fact-based
inquiry
there are complex and interacting
variables that have to be taken into
account
some of those developments that have
increased new hampshire revenue
through this past decade despite
the bbt and bet tax rate cuts
have included and here i'm going to go
into a short list
first there's been a massive we all know
this
at least those of us who've been with
ways and means for a while
a massive repatriation in recent years
of transnational corporate
profits coupled with an unusual volume
of profit generating corporate mergers
and transaction
transactions that were triggered by
considerations and that have resulted in
the resulted
in very large anomalous that's a dras
term
or one-time new hampshire business tax
revenues
that were estimated by dra to be about
200 million dollars
over several years and then
another influence on
another set of revenue enhancing
developments that have overwhelmed
tax rate cuts included
big changes large changes in taxable
private producing
business activity in new hampshire that
are these are activities that are
engaged in by very big
national and multinational entities
many many of which are identified by dra
as so-called
so-called water's edge companies
whose tax payments make up the bulk more
than 50 percent
of our total business tax revenues
and whose taxable activity here is i can
assure you
not influenced by march marginal changes
in our business tax rates
and also through this past decade and
always
through any period of time there have
been
and will be many other revenue enhancing
developments
including changes from year to year in
the federal tax law
that substantially modify the amount of
deductions and credits
taken on their returns by business
taxpayers and those two
influenced greatly uh revenues quite
we all know that future revenues
will always be affected by the coming
and going of peaks and troughs in the
business cycle
by other totally unpredictable
developments locally
regionally regionally nationally
and internationally this unpredictable
reality
is illustrated most recently by our
ongoing
struggle with the revenue impact of
covet
19 and by the infusion of very large
federal
grants dra's fiscal note
for hb 10 projects that its proposed
business tax cuts
could result in a long-term 53.7 million
dollar per year revenue
loss that's a static analysis and puts
aside
all the variables that i've just talked
about it's just
a mathematical calculation
i believe that is the best estimate
of impact that we have for this bill
and i also believe that we cannot accept
the level of revenue loss
that enactment of hb 10 will expose us
to
this bill is fiscally irresponsible
thank you representative ames
thank you mr chairman uh
uh representative uh almay and others
have uh
already uh talked about
uh what businesses
pay in terms of taxes and may not have a
uh itemized idea
of their property taxes business profits
taxes
but they that we we're pretty sure they
pay more in uh
property taxes in this state than um
they do business taxes and they've
talked about that in surveys among
bia members and others they
property taxes as being much more
onerous and difficult to deal with than
and with with this and these these
property taxes
go up every year and a lot of that is
due to the
withdrawal of reduction of state aid for
direct municipal and
county subsidies and for provision of
services such as police training
elder and assistance in public health
and of fixed public school system costs
i uh was a selectman in
a town right after the great recession
or during
right after it and um we saw
firsthand what um a loss of state
revenue
did uh and uh
uh the to the to the towns
uh and we had to scramble
to make
new budgets for this town
and had to raise the property taxes it
was
because we were forced to take up
expenses
that state had normally carried my
most most notably the uh
support of um retirement for public
officials police fire
and all that uh residents just couldn't
understand why if there were tax cuts
and budget cut
why the state was spending less money
why their property taxes went up
and uh selectmen in towns all across the
state were caught in a bind
to try to explain that and it was tough
and uh i just in my opinion
having been in the trenches like that i
think we're
causing we could be causing our towns
to look at this again force increases in
property taxes because of the
the word downshifting and i think that
creates a burden
on property taxpayers and that's
clearly my position on this because i've
experienced it
thank you thank you hello
thank you excuse the printer in the
background
i'm just looking up a few things
the discussion thus far has been about a
reduction in revenue
and yet when these tax cuts uh business
tax cuts were
instituted there was a substantial
increase
in revenue across the nation there has
been an
in increase in revenue when tax cuts
have been
implemented a recent cnbc
article she published
geez february 8th of 2021
indicates that there is a flow of jobs
and cash and business opportunity
from the high tax northeast to the low
tax
south so how do we stem that flow we
keep talking about
stimming the flow of the loss of
students from the area that
get a good education at unh or dartmouth
and then leave
we we talk about stemming the flow of
population
to the south well there's one way to do
that
let's make it more economically
advantageous
for people to stay in the northeast
just today west virginia has
introduced legislation to lower their
business taxes and they say west
virginia because
like new hampshire there are mountains
like new hampshire
they have a population that
has suffered for too long under a two
heavy attacks burden there was also an
argument that this shifts taxes down to
the towns
well who's responsible for what a town
spends
the town is responsible the citizens
are responsible if they want to build a
brand spanking new high school every
three years
that's up to the town it's not up to the
state
to cover their other expenses so they
can afford that
they need to do that they need to
address their own expenses
tax cuts have a multiplier effect upon
the economy they always have and they
always will be
whether it's the kennedy johnson uh tax
reductions
or the reagan tax reductions or the the
bush trump
uh tax uh income tax cuts
they have a multiplier effect they
stimulate the economy that make sure
that the working man has
money in his pocket because he has a job
and he's getting paid
so i have to
thank that uh for that uh interruption
sorry but the uh
tax cuts work they always have worked
they always will work so i'm in favor of
passing this
and it would make that motion right now
if allowed
[Music]
you all to represent you ready i'm all
done thank you
thank you representative representative
schoenberg
thank you mr chairman my concern about
house bill 10's purpose of tax rate
reductions for
bpt and bet is its effect upon the
state's
budget place in the recovery to meet the
needs
of granite staters i turned my research
for
impact information on what new hampshire
tax policies do
concerning public health risks and the
effect upon
economic recovery if tax rate reductions
are implemented the source i believe
that uses a
moderate factual approach to new
hampshire's
state tax policies is the new hampshire
fiscal policy institute
as representative murphy mentioned the
most recent issue
brief dated february 2021 by the new
hampshire
fiscal policy institute is titled
designing a state's budget to meet
new hampshire's needs during and after
the covet 19 crisis
the takeaway from this report when
applied to house bill
10 is will the proposal of permanent
tax reductions at the bpt and the bet
in house bill 10 help provide for elite
for the alleviating
of continued public health risks and
still support new hampshire's
economic recovery in reviewing uh
the policy brief a few summary points
were stressed
new hampshire residents still face
substantial challenges to affording
basic expenses
to particular provisions of health care
and social services
federal support has provided critical
relief but has not alleviated
hardship in a complete or sustained
manner
one in four granite staters report it
was somewhat or very difficult to pay
usual household expenses of which health
care is won
federal and state programs designed to
provide health coverage to people with
low incomes
or limited assets has increased by
nearly 20 percent in new hampshire
between the end of february 2020
to the end of january 2021 meaning
214 000 new hampshire residents are now
enrolled
in medicaid the second summary point
during this ongoing covet pandemic
granite staters who face or facing
severe health impacts
children who had more challenges to
being able to successfully participate
in remote schooling
and families who became less
housing and food secure are likely to be
in need
of additional supports beyond federal
monies
this is where new hampshire's state
budget policy must be designed to
stimulate
economic growth and help people through
these financially difficult times
the new hampshire fiscal policy
institute in this february 8
2021 brief writes that existing research
suggests
policies that deploy resources directly
to low-income residents as well as those
that support
public services employment and
infrastructure
are most effective at stimulating
economic growth
other policies such as permanent tax
reductions appear to have
a more limited impact the recent
position
stated that the bpt and the bet rate
reductions will
stimulate an upward projection of
revenue
are contrary not only to this report
but to the following reports issued in
the new hampshire fiscal policy
institute had issued on may 22nd
2019 this written statement in their
issue brief several business tax
reductions
that have taken effect in new hampshire
do not appear to be
responsible for the recent revenue
increases
and policy makers should not expect to
generate
additional revenue through tax
reductions
and if my colleagues across the aisle
feel that this is just an
unsubstantiated statement
there is within the september 10 2019
issue a section titled
rate reductions and funding ongoing
services
from three new hampshire government
units
the following projections about this
type
of tax rate cuts on revenue
quote revenue projections from the
governor
the legislature and the new hampshire
department of revenue administration's
updated projections all show a negative
impact on state revenues from
tax rate reductions the approach of the
trickle-down philosophical approach
of reducing the bpt and the bet
is not backed up by any factual
stipulations
i also urge my colleagues to look at the
new hampshire fiscal
policy institute brief of february 8
2021 closing by reducing this
critical revenue source house bill 10
will slow the economic recovery and
affect
state budget services to meet the
greater needs
among granite staters thank you mr
chairman
thank you representative schamberg
representative
so the techie forgets to unmute all
right
as a business owner i do understand the
desire to have lower business taxes
but our business pays about eight times
actually a little bit more
in property taxes than we do in business
taxes
so if reducing these tax rates increases
and the taxes of the members of my town
especially the elderly i think we need
to think twice
56 percent of new hampshire households
reported having difficulty paying normal
expenses
in the past seven days this was in a
recent survey done last month by the
fiscal policy institute
we can't cut the revenue stream that
helps our citizens in times of trouble
keeping dollars in the hands of people
is the biggest
economic multiplier cutting business
taxes is one of the lowest
i truly think this is a dangerous avenue
to go down
in these uncertain times uncertain times
not only in regard to the pandemic
economic impact but i also worry about
other legislation that may compound the
effect
of these reductions in revenue
and i also think we do have the lowest
business tax in new england is that not
correct
anyways um i think we need to be in this
together
and and try to take care of our populace
now
instead of trying to tempt business into
new hampshire
with reducing our business taxes further
thank you
thank you representative and
fair i just wanted to respond um
to a couple of the arguments that have
been presented this morning
first from representative ulri his
example of bringing up west virginia's
business tax cuts he made the claim that
you know the result of those business
tax cuts was a revenue boom for the
state
i think we just need to take a step back
and recognize that west virginia's
variables for their economy were
numerous and
that you know the cut of the business
tax may not have directly correlated to
the revenue increase
and i think specifically it's worthy to
point out that
west virginia does have an income tax
so while that state's example is
relevant
um to his argument i think we have a
more compelling case
to look at and that specifically relates
to the
state of kansas i'm not sure if everyone
on our committee is familiar
with that a recent um 2013-2017
experiment
by the state legislature and the
governor there
so as a brief brief rundown i'd just
like to remind everyone
that in 2013 governor
sam brownback initiated a series of
um i guess it was structured tax cuts
for business taxes as well as a
reduction in the state's
income tax to levels that were much much
lower than the previous experiment
uh experience and um over
a series of three to four years um it
was his
experiment or his hypothesis that
you know these results from those tax
cuts would
bring um
i guess like higher turnout higher
increases of job availability
as well as you know boosting this
economic growth
and making the overall constituents of
kansas richer
because of those cuts and you know
was just
sheer economic destruction in the state
with a very difficult time of supporting
their systems
and programs across the board and their
budgets
basically imploded and i think you know
you don't have to take my word for it
there are several
worthy journalistic news articles about
this
you know series of four years uh oh four
and a half years
of this implosion and you know
the idea that trickle-down economics is
going to work on a state basis by
reducing
business taxes has been proven to have
failed
it's the kansas experiment
is not something we need to repeat here
in new hampshire
and we can do better we can learn from
their mistakes
and we can you know give our state the
ability
um to boost our revenues or at least
keep them stable during a serious
pandemic
as opposed to trying to recreate
the same failed experiment in new
hampshire we we don't need to do kansas
bidding here so let's let's use our
brains let's
see the experience that other states
have had and know that it was an abject
failure
and not be doomed to repeat that history
here
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative
hacken phillips mr chairman may i
speaking
yes um
representative hackenfeld's uh
characterization of the
kansas uh experiment uh was
rather partisan and uh not entirely
accurate
according to recent activities uh if you
take a look at your news feeds uh
you'll see that kansas just uh rejected
an
increase in taxation you'll also notice
if you look at
several of the different uh ranking
systems that exist throughout the state
that kansas
ranks relatively high and higher than
the uh
that new hampshire does in the tax
burden on the taxpayers
and their economic prosperity
the to me biased information from the
new hampshire physical institute
having attended several of their uh
lectures
it was purely anti-republican and
partisan
uh i i disregard totally anything that
they have to say
uh because of their
presentations that i've attended uh
at any rate the point that i wish to
make is
is that tax cuts work
they have worked they have always worked
they've worked on a national level they
can work they work on a state level
and kansas is a hell of a lot better off
than new hampshire is as far as a
tax burden is concerned thank you mr
chair for the opportunity today
thank you representative representative
from gene
again thank you uh ginnygan represent
thank you mr chairman
i just want to maybe take a look at this
in a slightly
different way um i agree with many of
the things
that uh representative uh baxter said
and um and also those who have um
talked about the decreases um
when businesses are increasing in um
in profitability when when taxes are
decreased but i want to look at a
slightly different
way as well um i think i think new
hampshire can potentially use
um i mean the covid thing yes it's
created a lot of uncertainty
but let's not forget that
we are competing with other states let's
make new hampshire as competitive as
possible
let's win this thing and basically
new hampshire as massachusetts for
example i just looked it up on the state
their state website they have an eight
percent business profits tax
um at 7.5 percent we begin to
separate ourselves from massachusetts
we're seeing that
from states like new york i mean people
are fleeing
businesses are fleeing states like
california new york
places where the tax burden is high
the the covered restrictions are high
while we do have covered restrictions
they're nowhere as near as onerous
as the states i just mentioned so
new hampshire so as as people
look around and say you know maybe we
want to relocate towards to a state that
has lower taxes
less restrictions let's also look at our
coveted numbers
i just looked at this morning's update
and it looks like
we currently have about 3 170 active
cases
in the state down from over 6 000 just
about a month ago
we also have about 159 hospitalizations
down from over 350
about a month ago so we are we are
moving
in a in a good direction even though
we're in february this is typically a
very cold month
uh infections are typically high
and yet we're moving in a very positive
direction as far as coving cases
so i think we use this opportunity to
make
let's make new hampshire stand out let's
think of this as a competition with
other states
and not just if we reduce the tax 0.2
percent
it's not going to make any difference
let's also think about
how it affects people emotionally who
want to move and relocate from other
states and that could that can be a huge
boon
to new hampshire long term so i just
wanted to add that perspective to this
discussion thank you mr chairman thank
uh next is representative
it's gorg you've got the two of us back
to back the hard names
um i just wanted to actually uh
representative spoke
i i completely agree with him we are in
a great
direction and um to echo others
it's hard to change things when we are
already in such a great
position um and i just i also
just a small comment new hampshire is so
unique
we all know that um and the fact that
we're comparing ourselves to other
states that are not
in the new england region is very
difficult
i actually did just look up the west
virginia center on
budget and policy has many articles
actually about why the business tax cut
failed um they ended up um
having horrible issues with this and i
would encourage everybody to do a little
bit more research if we're comparing to
them
um especially with their education
funding
which of course we we're not unique in
that we do obviously have our education
issues um but
i mean if we have a good thing going and
people are moving here and we've been
told that our
um population is growing
now is not the time to mess with what we
have
i don't know since i'm new to the
committee why there's a sense of urgency
to this
um but i would love to see
next year or the year after we we look
at this again
and kind of ride it out for right now
and see what ends up happening
so thank you well thank you
representative
thank you already on
first i want to to point out that phil
slatten came out of the
totally nonpartisan lbao
audit program he has a very long history
of extremely detailed data-driven
analysis and
he has been trying for
some time to balance between both
parties i realized that in the past
the republicans even decided that the
center for public policy studies
which was founded by a republican and
which had
on speaker um
oh i'm losing names now but had
had our only woman republican speaker
who was quite conservative on the board
and
had a board that went from very far left
to very far right
and mostly in the middle they were all
committed to data analysis
on the republicans at that time started
to try to characterize it
as left-wing because there was
no no left wing
place and i think that that's what is
happening
again it is very unfortunate for
data-driven research
in this country in this state
but on i
also wanted to point out that the whole
country
is going in the right direction at the
moment on covid but that
the medical community is
very worried about on this reversing
with the variance spread
right now in the whole country
and that we are
a very small state with the
a unique completely unique track tax
structure
that people in other states always ask
me how
do you do that uh and
on we can't compare ourselves
with giants that have the problems of
giants
in new york and california
uh and texas so
on that being said
i wanted to point out another data
driven
group which does have a left
left side approach to things but it is
on it has the best micro macro
economic model for taxation outside the
congressional budget office
and it has been doing that for 30 years
that is the dc base
institute on taxation and economic
policy itep
in 2017 as the congress prepared to pass
massive federal tax cuts for the rich
itep wrote the following to the
lawmakers
for more than four decades supply-side
ideologues have promoted the myth
that tax cuts for the wealthy are
self-financing
and the benefits eventually trickle down
to everyone
else despite real-life evidence that tax
cuts for the rich benefit the rich
not even the reality of 40 years of
widening
economic income inequality
or the current economic expansion in
which the benefits primarily
flowed to wealthy households have
stopped anti-tax
proponents from peddling the enormous
uh erroneous idea that top heavy tax
cuts will eventually benefit
ordinary working people
we know also from the latest edition of
iteps who pays
that in 2017 in new hampshire
the top one percent of families paid
only three percent of their income
in state and local taxes whereas the
lower 80 percent
paid six and a half to nine percent of
their income
in taxes our business profits tax
has been working against these
inequities slightly reducing the
economic the extreme
advantage of our richest citizens
because of this the new business
tax cuts will further erode tax equity
in new hampshire
and because they are slight and will
have no effect whatsoever
on the economy except that they are
going to cut
services the businesses and the citizens
need on
this is not going to greatly reduce
tax equity in new hampshire but it is
the end of a long series of tax cuts
which have happened to coincide
on before the tax impact has been felt
of those tax cuts has happened to
coincide
with uh national level
and and state tax
waves that are built in to
our system and into the federal system
thank you
thank you representative representative
walkman
yeah mute can you hear me all right yes
uh thank you mr chairman um i just
wanted to point out a couple of things
you know something that was uh well
understood in the last term
and that's as we were sort of evaluating
the impact of the tax cuts that were
made
um it was also made clear that the
massive repatriation
of profits and our ability to tax those
profits
resulted in a huge but temporary
revenue boost which really
uh blurred the the sort of return on
investment
assessment on how those tax cuts
affected us but it was made clear that
a massive amount of revenue came from
that temporary repatriation of funds
which is a federal
law that was passed the tax cuts and
jobs act
we can't depend on that to happen again
we should not forget that that's where
those revenues came from
and so the idea that those tax cuts paid
for themselves i think we know better
secondly you know we should hesitate to
compare business tax rates with other
states
i think that's way too narrow of you
considering you know we don't have taxes
that those states do
also our property taxes are a burden
that those other states don't have
and i think the most appropriate way to
assess the tax burden for businesses
that want to come to new hampshire or
state new hampshire is to look at things
holistically
and we already have a very friendly
business tax environment when you
consider all the taxes that we don't
have
and if we're really interested in making
things easier for business we should
look at what we can do
for property taxes uh and finally
just sort of a kind of a personal
opinion here you know
we talk a lot about other states
and the idea that people are businesses
are fleeing these other states and
disregard completely that these states
have massive economies in part because
of the investments they make in their
infrastructure in education
which makes people want to invest with
their businesses and with their families
in those states
and it's always struck me as a bit
disingenuous that we
you know mock these states at the same
time that we
talk about wanting to pursue a greater
and stronger economy for new hampshire
we mock states that have rather
impressive economies
um so you know i i agree that new
hampshire is a unique and special place
and we should protect that
but you know investments there's a
difference between a cost and an
investment and i i
really fear for new hampshire's future
if we continue to divest
at a time when i think we could be
protecting these revenue streams
investing in education
uh lowering property taxes uh
and you know really investing in our
future that's all i wanted to say thank
you
thank you representative uh
representative
romney
are you muted pat
thank you mr chair uh we've
you know we've had our own experiment
here
we have actual real data if you looked
at the graph that
representative major used and when he
introduced a bill
from 2011 to 2015
our our business tax growth was anemic
it averaged about 534 million dollars
annually but there was really no growth
going on
when you look at 2016 to 2020
that number jumped to 727 million
average
so we compared average five years to
another average five years 534 million
to 727 million or 193 million growth
yes it is true in that math for the last
five years as
was the repatriation but also for the
last year in that number the 2020
there was a hit due to covet which kind
of i won't say it
absolutely cancels out each other but uh
but even if you said 193 million average
growth was too high take out
repatriation
for that one year you know maybe that's
maybe the average is 150 million
increase
in revenues i mean if i came down from
mars and i looked at this graph and i
said
wow look at those look at those first
five years there boy that's
that's not much growth at all and then
it just jumped right off the scale when
you look at the chart
and it all started in 2016
when we had our first incremental
reduction in in taxes
again i i'm i've i'm i'm i've no
statistics
i know this is really a multivariate
issue but
if we just focus on that and that cause
and effect is caused by many things and
effective
and all of that but i i i
can't walk away by just looking at this
chart by saying
uh the tax cuts didn't have some
positive impact on
very increased significant increases in
our our revenues
from our businesses and we talk about
education
[Music]
we have to remind ourselves we are
ranked
very very high on our education system
here
doing things the way we do them uh
we are the outcomes the outcome measures
that which is the most important thing
the outcome scores of our students in
this state
are extremely high compared to most
other states
so uh you know we can use all the
arguments we want
uh all we're trying to do with this bill
is to continue to stimulus
our business businesses to stay here and
to move here
and i think from the chart that was
handed out and if you
i find it hard to argue that there
wasn't some success here
uh you know the only only thing that you
could argue is that maybe the
repatriation helped
but but even after the repatriation
ended
even in the covert year we were we were
significantly above where we were you
know five years ago
or four years ago so i'll leave it at
that
thank you very much thank you
representative romney
representative elliott
you're still muted bob okay
yes sorry about that um
correct me if i'm wrong but it's my
understanding now that
the businessman pays 35
of our state budget
um and i
and i also believe that um
many businesses are not in deep trouble
right now but many of them have gone out
of business
completely so i look at this bill in a
more simple way than the scholarly
presentations that i've just heard
as a way of helping the businessman
because if i lower his tax bill
by any uh measure that to me
is going to help him and right now i
feel that the businessman needs our help
and that's the whole
purpose of this bill now if i'm wrong
and if it doesn't work out
in two years we can always change the
rate back
to the present rate and that way
uh the other side will have their
victory as well so i'll be brief
i'm in favor of this bill i think it
time we help the business man thank you
very much mr chairman
thank you represent elliott
yes i i wanted to uh read to you
a letter that i got from a constituent
that i actually don't know
and i did look her up on the voter list
she's an unenrolled
uh voter she lives in whitefield which
is the largest of my
towns in my district uh colossians
and she wrote this to me and she wrote
it to
uh two other elected officials from the
legislature
as a resident and her name is stephanie
kelleher
she lives at 148 bray hill road
in whitefield as a resident and property
owner in whitefield
i wanted to write and express my concern
about the governor's plans to cut
several business tax rates
and the interest in dividends tax she
wrote this to me on the evening of
january 28th
as new hampshire residents we already
pay some of the highest property taxes
in the country
and in whitefield in particular we pay
higher than average compared to the rest
of the state
where do you expect to make up this
extra money
and how do you expect people to continue
living here
if property rates continue to go up
why would you eliminate a tax on
interest in dividends
in reality this tax only affects
rich people but getting rid of it will
affect
all of us who are struggling just to pay
our property taxes
i think something needs to be done
statewide
to do something about our ridiculously
high property tax rates
so i think this is not an unusual
view by citizens
not only of the north country but across
the state
state is picking up less of municipal
costs
retirement costs so when you go to a
selections meeting
you hear them talk about these things
that are in the municipal budgets
that they can't control retirement costs
being one of them
other aspects of policing and so forth
that
people want to have and it costs them
more money now
and this difficulty that people are
having with paying their property taxes
it means it's hard for young people to
afford housing
even if they can afford to buy the house
then they have to pay the property tax
every year
and it affects the elder citizens and
here in
northern new hampshire i'm typical i'm
an
older citizen and the property taxes
become more difficult
every year so i ask you
not this year when we're struggling as a
state
like the rest of the country to deal
with what this pandemic will mean
to us not to cut business taxes
this year and not to support this bill
thank you dr representative tucker uh
representative model and then we're
going to take a five minute break
representative camaro thank you mr chair
um i wanted to point out that the
numbers that came in
you know the final numbers for 2020 for
the state in june
i would would it be the four months of
covid
march april may june though those
figures
those those receipts were based on 2019
profits from various businesses they had
nothing to do with 2020. the only
thing that had to do with 2020 is the
estimates
which are based on 2019
so i don't think we can look at the
final numbers for that year
and say oh look we did great even in the
time of covid because
we weren't in the time of covid in 2019
and everything that came in
from january to to june was based on
2019.
so i just wanted to point that out thank
you
okay uh there's no other hands let's
take a five minute break
mr chair yes i there was one attendee
that set his hand up the whole time
i didn't know if you wanted to i will
take him first right after
you
so
okay
that was a nice idea mr chairman
all right on house bill 10
we've heard a lot of discussion we're
going to
uh exact that tomorrow
and tomorrow when it comes to the exec
for house bill 10
we don't want to repeat any of the
discussion
if there's any new discussion fine but i
think
people know how they really want to vote
on this
and and the good reason reason that they
feel they want to vote on this on each
side
i don't think we're going to change
anybody's views
so when we get back to house bill 10
tomorrow
unless there's new information i think
we need to
mr chairman there was apparently i have
no idea who it was
someone who had their hand up for quite
a long time before
and you said you'd take him or her after
allow him to talk is
jeffrey does you want to talk on house
bill 10
because we're in a work session now
and discussing among ourselves and if
it's on house bill 10
yes i i guess i'll have to
you are given permission to talk you
have been given permission
mr jefferson mr jim sorry
mr jefferson is this relative to house
bill 10
it is not i had raised my hand to talk
about house bill 528
but i was just i was just sitting and
listening to
all the other bills so it is not related
if we go on to house build 15 house bill
15 shouldn't
relative to encoding under the meals and
rooms tax facilitators of
internet transactions of motor vehicle
rentals
and facilitators of internet
transactions
representative
most of her caucus is is going to
support an arc to pass on this
and in the republican caucus
it's about the same but there's an open
question
about a new tax
and we need to get that answered
and i'd like to do is have the
dra there tomorrow and
and so what we'll do is we'll hold this
until tomorrow
get that answer and then i think we can
go in the executive session if there's
no
if anybody uh doesn't have any
additional to talk about on that
representative schomburg uh mr chairman
uh if we're gonna hold this so you get
an answer uh
would that be the time when i should
maybe make my presentation on what i
think about
this being a new tax
a matter of fact you could do that right
now
this bill house bill 15 as introduced by
the prime
sponsor from londonderry is
contrary i think to the prime sponsor's
viewpoint
it is a new tax on new hampshire small
independent entrepreneur
business individuals who are willing to
fill a niche
that the regular brick and mortar
business models have left unattended
these small independent entrepreneur
business owners provide a personal
interaction
for what's best in their community and
new hampshire
they found a way to promote themselves
and their personal services
the prime sponsor says passing this bill
will level the playing field
how doesn't this give the established
brick and mortar business models
an advantage because of their deep and
established
money pockets my colleague from
greenland
who chaired the subcommittee on this
issue last year
did an excellent job of delving into the
mechanics
of these platforms which gives
the small independent business owner and
private individuals
another way to promote their services
these small business owners need as many
platforms as possible
these platforms are like the old
bulletin board outside the grocery or
feed store
where you could pin up your service car
to hopefully have someone contact you
we are now in the 21st century let's say
this is a new tax
versus the prime sponsors opinion
what the prime sponsor has done in house
bill 15
is to broaden the definition
of operator and rental of the vehicle
usually private person to now be
that the term operator shall include a
rental facilitator
and a room facilitator isn't this new
doesn't this one
including a new
i heard from the prime sponsor earlier
this year
say we want to reduce your taxes
how does this reduce the small business
entrepreneur's
tax when he says she
didn't have one before
isn't this a new regulation that wasn't
here before
i heard the prime sponsor early
in this new year's sake we want to
reduce regulation that businesses can
expand
they can hire more people attract more
business
to the state of new hampshire creating
more jobs
another burden on the small business
owner
didn't have this government will they
stay in business
what happened to reducing the size
of state government in new hampshire
the small business independent
entrepreneurs
a personal interaction for what's best
in their community in all new hampshire
many do this as a way to improve their
financial security
especially during the coveted pandemic
these small independent entrepreneurs
are looking for provide for themselves
and family
new tax on facilitators is being
to be included under the meals tax
as i have said the prime sponsor said
early
in january we don't access at this
particular
point where we have to make
sure businesses succeed
businesses get back open again
and they put people back raising taxes
is not
on the table i guess broadening the
definition
of an operator or a private car rental
is not a tax increase service owner
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative schoenberg
um representative alani
who's who else was talking yes tom we
heard you
yeah yes we heard you on i'd like to ask
the previous speaker if he has any
evidence
that any of the remote facilitation work
is being done by small businesses in
local towns
for a very long time and currently
on the brick and mortar real estate
agents
in small towns have been paid collecting
and paying
this tax for their clients uh who are
renting their sites can't hear you
you can't oh
we can tom oh
oh dear do i have to start from the
beginning
because i was uh addressing a question
to
to the previous speaker can you hear me
she's in and out i guess i'm too close
to lebanon
you were going out too tom yeah i can
hear you now
okay so can you hear me yeah
he said he goes yes okay no i don't
have any i do susan i don't have any
uh facts or data on that this is a
philosophical approach okay well i i
will continue then
the uh current
small businesses that do
collect and pay this tax that are
resident in
our towns in new hampshire and are
have clients who are usually from out of
state with second homeowners they rent
their places
on out to people on
those facilitators are brick and mortar
and they are already collecting and
paying this tax
to the dra on the dra
also goes after people that on a less
uh on frequent
basis will will rent out a room for
instance i had a guy who was quite upset
about it who got
caught in lebanon because he
had decided that he could help pay for
his apartment's rent by renting out the
back room to visiting nurses
and he hadn't realized that he owed a
tax on that under our current law
he does um and
i had to tell him that uh so
on this is the situation right now
for rooms for cars
on the only information that we have
found has been
very large on remote
facilitators who are working
nationwide from other states and who
have the bandwidth
to to uh
advertise their product widely over the
websites
and i don't know theoretically a
a single small facilitator of that type
could
develop in new hampshire
but on we haven't heard from anyone
that was trying to do that and it does
take quite a lot to make yourself
nationally known
sometimes it requires a certain amount
of
creativity but and could happen
but given that what we are just trying
to do
is to even the playing field between
the the remote sellers that are selling
uh a product that is the same in the
same
manner as the people that are brick and
mortar that are
resident within our state and
that is not a new tax that is
making the tax fairer to
to the same businesses and
under our constitution and the supreme
court
generally decide when you go to them
to that effect but we are waiting as i
understand for the
department of revenue administration to
okay representative romney
thank you mr chair um yeah i was on that
subcommittee
with that representative malloy uh
chaired last year
you know we spent a lot of time on this
bill uh trying to get the language
correct
uh we worked with sean thomas who
unfortunately is no longer with the dra
but he
he's a lawyer who who wrote most of this
language
and we went through a whole bunch of
iterations on it
uh but philosophically uh
yes and there's some questions in our
caucus about the language and that's why
we we do want to hear uh not for me but
from other members of our caucus
that we we want to hear from dra i think
we'll get
satisfaction once we hear from dra on on
some of the meaning of certain things
but it is i mean we're not talking mom
and pop here
uh maybe you know we're talking airbnb
we're talking
on the on the uh room side and toro
who's getting bigger by the day on the
auto side
and it's it we view this and we view it
last year as a
committee as a fairness issue uh
between the brick and mortar and the you
know hey we're in the
you know 21st century now with all these
platforms that are out there
uh we felt that was appropriate to tax
and all the facilitator does the
facilitator is not being taxed the
facilitator
is making sure that the person uh
renting the car from another individual
or renting the room for another original
uh tax on the the uh rumor males
uh about the reveals the the uh the yeah
room mail tax
which is the uh uh and
and the five percent and collects that
his job is to collect that not tax him
because we're actually taxing a person
who rents the room
and rents the car uh
instead of from a brick and mortar
operation from uh from an e
e-commerce operation and uh so
that just i just wanted to say those
things and uh we'll see
what happens tomorrow when we we have
dras input thank you
doctor ms spillsbury thank you mr
chairman
i've had no involvement in this bill my
exposure to it is purely in the work of
this committee in the last couple of
weeks
and in reading the language i don't find
anything
to be ambiguous or controversial
about this bill i think the bill is
plainly and well written
i view it from a marketing perspective
the product hasn't changed what's
happened
is a new channel of
has been introduced and that channel of
distribution
is simply a new innovation
just simply a a different form of
booking agent
so i would grant some of what
representative schaumburg said
the definition of operator has been
expanded
to include these new innovative entities
um and so we have rental facilitator and
room facilitator they're both defined
and they're defined very much in
parallel
if you look at line 25
the subject that's being
or product that's being taxed
is quote rental of a motor vehicle to a
renter
all of the words that come before that
are just descriptors of a variety of
marketing agents so
rel facility means any person having any
right
accessibility or authority to
to offer reserve book arrange for
remarket distribute broker resell
coordinate or otherwise facilitate
what rental of a motor vehicle
to a renter rent rental
of a motor vehicle to a renter is the
product
it hasn't changed the exact
same structure occurs in the definition
of room facilitator and
page two in line three what's being text
occupancy to an occupant the addition
of someone facilitating doesn't change
that
so it's not a new tax and as
representative
raleigh just said the person being taxed
is the person who's renting the room or
the car
all we're asking the facilitator to do
is be responsible for collecting it
that's all thank you representative
thank you mr chair um
yeah on on this bill i agree with
representative almi and as abram
others have said about the issue of
fairness uh the market's changing and
a pro growth and just a fair policy is
applying attacks
equally to different businesses of the
same
tax um so this bill is not intended to
create a new tax
um i do think there's there's a concern
about this potentially applying to
travel agents as it's written which i
know is not the intent of anyone
so i think literally just a one sentence
amendment in there saying this shall not
apply to travel agents would be
important
and i think that's why it's important to
continue to tweak this
but i think the bill is pretty close um
so you know hopefully we can tweak it um
and then
um there sounds like there's a wide
amount of support um
among the committee and then we can get
thank you representative baxter uh
representative salesforce
uh thank you mr chairman just briefly i
support this bill for two reasons
uh first i really think the idea of
fairness is very important
and secondly for those who aren't there
our subcommittee did a very thorough
job researching this bill and so i think
what we came up with was just based
representative
thank you can you hear me yes
oh good on i just wanted to suggest we
add the travel agent question
to the dras list
yeah because on i was under the
impression
on that if it's a room that they would
pay i'm not sure
on and i presume i mean they don't pay
they collect and
send it on and that the same thing would
apply to cars
any other comments uh
well representative romney has a hand up
yeah i'm just trying to figure out where
a travel agent fits in in this whole
discussion i guess a travel agent
if if someone said they wanted uh to go
to their truck let's say they have a
travel agent they use all the time
and they said they wanted to rent a room
through airbnb all the travel agent
would do
i would imagine i'm guessing here would
be to contact
airbnb which is the platform the
middleman
to in turn find a room for them
to to rent uh so or you know or a house
or whatever it might be
so i'm not quite sure and then there we
have a different financial relationship
between the travel agent
and the facilitator or air b in this
case airbnb
and i i don't see where in this language
there'd be attacks on it but we can ask
you know
that's a good question representative
baxter
let's clarify it and put it to bed once
and for all
i think the question on travel agency
comes in on line 15 of the first page of
the bill
where it where it basically says um
arkansas without any deduction of any
account including any fees service or
other charge required to be paid by
by the occupancy of a room facilitator i
think the
travel agency's concern is that their
service fee
that they tack on to make money is being
taxed
thank you mr chairman i i think what was
just said is
accurate but not the point
a fee that's tacked on as a booking fee
it's a marketing expense is part of the
process and the total cost of selling
representative bernstein thank you mr
chair
um i too was on the committee last term
the subcommittee that looked at this
bill and i have the bill pulled up on my
screen it was
um hb 1558 from 2019
and the current iteration of this bill
expands the scope of the bill and that
that's why i'm just not
i'm i still haven't rendered a final
decision on how i'm going to vote
i just have some concerns that this this
bill is much more inclusive
than the 19 line bill we we looked at
two years ago
um two years ago there was no mention
of taxing fees or services
it was simply a question of fairness
between
uh the platform that toro
is operating on as compared to rental
car agencies
but now all of a sudden there's new
language regarding fees and services and
i'm reluctant to support it because
i i think that perhaps we're
casting too wide of net uh i will i
i i'm looking forward to hearing from
dra
so we can get some interpretation of
some of this language but
um this is not the bill we looked at two
years ago
representative romney jump in
when you when you pull that up did you
pull up the original
you got to make sure when you're looking
at the bill it should be the bill that
that we
we voted on at the end not as introduced
we did a lot of amending to the bill
that went to the floor that we all
passed so can you please double check
that
i i'm looking at the original bill and
you're correct uh representative abrami
and i will pull out the
version we voted on thank you thank you
okay
ruxin i don't see any of the
hands so
looks like we can move on and bring this
up again tomorrow
and hopefully we get the bra
the next is i'm going to skip over 210
but go to house bill 306
relative to the revenue estimates while
operating under emergency orders caused
by
and susan you had some
yes on we were worried
and i was particularly worried haven't
had to deal with this for a long time
that on this is our normal practice
at this point that when the economy is
shifting
we do revenue estimates more often
and we both of us have had trouble
getting
agencies at some points to uh cooperate
with that and so i understand your
intent
in doing this but in limiting it
to just the emergency executive orders
under covid and the fiscal years 21-23
we are sending a signal that we are no
longer
when we need to do so going to be able
to tell the agencies look
we have to to do these revenue estimates
on a more frequent basis
and so on i wanted to suggest
that on you
take out everything amended and take out
everything relevant
to the fiscal years 21 23 and decoded
pandemic and
emergency maybe even emergency orders
because we have quite frequently had
had shaky economies at the same time
without emergency orders being used
in fact these are the first emergency
orders since the bill
put them in i think in our first year in
1996.
do you have a language that
you would recommend but a
but i could write it in five minutes
after we finish
that'll be fine and we can bring it up
tomorrow okay
the next is house bill
330. my hand was up
my hand was up on the last bill on 306
yep okay go ahead real quick uh
represent army i agree 100 to broaden it
and uh do we think we can get an
amendment by tomorrow
i don't know how quick they work over no
oh us
these days i know i'm
i think by the end of today when i sent
to them late last night
on another bill okay so i
i think something like this that was
also a very simple thing and
we'll be getting to it i think okay
thank you
okay
locations
discussion
[Music]
representative
thank you on this
is the other bill that i was talking
about
on we had on felt strongly
on our side on we had agreed with
representative abrami that
the cap should not be lifted at this
point
and so i sent for an amendment
which would allow tier two sports wagers
to go forward
but avoid removing the cap
okay and i think we just we discussed
that uh before when we were
hearing the bill about the importance
so you're going to have an amendment
that
yes yes it's already being done in the
ols
okay representative
something to say yes uh
i'm glad to hear that uh we all have a
an understanding of the tier 2 system
where you know we've got these two brick
and mortar
uh facilities and people apparently that
go there to
do some sports wagering or have dinner
or whatever have to go on their mobile
devices to uh
to make bets that they can't make at the
brick and mortar places
along the lines of the uh expansion of
uh
you know the uh ten brick and mortar
facilities
and if uh if charlie mcintyre is
stalling the call
like we spoke of briefly yesterday mr
chairman i
i think uh both the lottery
and the vendor draftkings have a lot to
say in that
um and it's it's my understanding so i i
don't think there'd be a problem with
that being amended it's my understanding
that uh they don't expect to get to the
ten locations as it is so
uh okay shall we one of the attendees i
could bring him in
uh good morning mr chairman can you hear
me yes we can
charlie hi good morning mr members of
the committee charlie mcintyre hampshire
lottery here
um i believe the question is do we
anticipate getting to
10 locations in any time soon the answer
is no so
um we are two now
we have two more we're looking at
actively and a fifth one
potentially so um within the next two
years it would be incredibly unlikely we
would
okay so that shouldn't be a problem with
the proposed amendment we don't i don't
sir no okay
any other questions i want to ask
challenge
representative romney yeah this actually
is a
question for for uh charlie so
yeah my hypothesis that i threw out
there the other day
when this bill was uh being uh
introduced
was would it be a disincentive
given that there's a high risk here and
uh
to bender and then and then there's only
so many people who are going to be
willing to wager on sports betting in
the state
plus we do still have the the the the
apps on their people's phones so not
everybody's going to go to a
brick-and-mortar place
so what if i was thinking of jumping in
as a business to being a location for
this
would it be a disincentive to them to
jump in knowing that
is unlimited number of locations
potentially that would that would eat
into the
total number of uh you know total number
of people that are going to bet
anyway uh that was my only hypothesis
that
i i i don't know the answer to that i
just don't know if you have an opinion
on that
knowing what you do about these folks
that run the the charitable gaming
locations or
other locations they may want to jump
into this
i mean certainly we haven't had the
issue yet only because they have been so
separated in terms of the locations i
imagine that's the case
that a business would would be less
likely to invest significant capital in
making it a first
class outfit i can tell you that the
customer base between the physical
locations and the mobile
is entirely different folks who go to
physical locations
are folks who just aren't comfortable
with their phone or like being in person
uh and tend to be older and wealthier
folks who do it on they use the phone
and computer
to be younger and not as wealthy and bet
much less per wager
yep okay that actually does make sense
joe thank you
thank you okay
we had a brief discussion yesterday
thanks to representative abrami about
how it worked out for
new hampshire on the super bowl game
and maybe in a paragraph you could
explain it
um representative tucker not to get
ahead of me i've been asked the question
but i've been asked to present to you
folks next week
on this very question so i was going to
prepare something ahead of it i'm not
ready yet
thank you thank you any further
questions with charlie
or anybody
i see no more hands up so then
tomorrow hopefully we'll have that
amendment
that leaves us i believe with two bills
left
and 568 now 210
is an act increasing exemptions under
the interest and dividend tax
and decrease in the total amount of
research and development credits against
house bill 568
is an act increasing the exemptions to
the interest and dividends tax
and repealing the tax in 2025
is 210 lines built that is
that's i think i think there's
uh well at least i'll speak to our
caucus
and i forget about the caucus first i
mean i i kind of supported the idea of
increasing the exemptions and it seems
like our caucus
agrees to that now the degree to that
to how much they should be increased is
still being debated
within our caucus at this point
so and i think we're also all in
agreement that
if we do something we should not uh
reduce the uh the r d
tax credit um i think we heard some
testimony during our hearings a couple
weeks ago from businesses that
well two of them anyway that told us why
they didn't
see that as a good idea and i think the
bia and other
really discouraging us to do that i mean
that that this is a carrier bill from a
couple years ago where we were making an
attempt to make this a budget neutral
uh thing that we would reduce the
uh increase the ex exemptions
and but pay for it by reducing the r d
tax credit money so uh
yeah i i think we're i think as a caucus
we're going to come down one way or
another
on this um but
i don't think we're there yet uh other
than those two principles
are are definitely r d reduction in r d
tax credit
and as i'm also thinking of the other
bill as well when i'm making the
statement
uh and that let's this is one of those
we hope that uh
all of us can kind of come together on a
sort of a happy medium here so
as best we can but anyway that's where
that's where
my mind is on this uh and i i don't i
don't think our caucus is
is solidified behind uh a final
recommendation
representation you want to speak
thank you on this
this tax is a very difficult one for
my caucus because as i said yesterday
on that triangle represents
people at all income levels in
in all of the lower level
taxpayers the first three layers at
least of
low-level taxpayers and some of them
are low-level but
very wealthy otherwise since we do not
have an income tax there's no way
to do a reasonable exemption
that for the poorest people who depend
on that money
on without also giving the exemption to
people on
that for whom that is just a very small
part of a very large
income that they have and
um so
i think we would be if the exemptions
haven't been raised for a very long time
and partly because of that reason
and the tax uh provides
a very significant amount of money to
our budget on
so we would be i think
open to discussing an exemption
that was uh lower than the one that is
in here
that would target to the lowest amounts
that are paid
it would also reduce the paperwork for a
huge number
of people that are now paying nothing or
one dollar but have to file
because they come in and out of that
exemption level
and um but on
i i'd like to see
the chair ask dra
to to model what
on how much it would cost at
a couple of different exemptions of his
choice
on that we're in between what the bill
offers uh which is about six million
dollars
usually of of money to us to our budget
on and and no increase
in the exemption so uh
and i think that they must be able to do
that since they could do the triangle
anything about the r d
oh and uh yeah we we would rather
not uh at this time consider
reducing the r d tax credit
we we have been getting some more
information
from the the people that are
using it it would be really nice if we
could get
the business and economic affairs or the
dra
to provide more information
about how it's being used
you want the incremental increase
or decrease in taxes
for increasing the exemption yes how
much it would cost
the budget right and our revenue
estimates to uh to
put the exemption at
2000 or at 2 200.
i forget where it starts at 2400.
that's so sorry i was trying to remember
i don't know why
i've been paying this for years why it
would
would why it sticks in my head is 1800
um but just go to go up
above 2400 at at
200 on 200 dollar increments
in 200 well
make the exemption 2600. and see
what that does make the exemption at 20
800 and see what that does
yeah and these are steps in that
about 3 000. because
like going from 2400
yes it does but if we going from
2400 to 3500 i guess is
it it's about five million dollars
if they want to reduce the
yeah the question is how many of those
people are well for one thing some of
them are couples
with uh who are over 65 and they get
more money
uh more exemption but how many of those
people who are paying
one to 500 for instance are
are actually
covered by by a
2600 to 2800 a 3 000
exemption and i think that
that the dra probably can
okay anything
else on this particular bill
representative janigan thank you mr
chairman
um yeah just a couple points one is
i am for increasing the exemption to
which would help people on the lower
scale there and even at
but if you only include intro increase
it by 200
205 percent of 200 is ten dollars so
you'd only be
relieving that taxpayer of ten dollars
so you probably do need
bigger and i would be for a bigger
bigger increase
um the and the other point i want to
make it and it sounds like everyone is
for not coupling these
or most are for against not coupling
this with the research and development
uh tax credit i mean in my mind
effectively you're trying to couple a
personal
tax with a with a with a
exemption that helps businesses and
probably not a good idea to be mixing
personal and business taxes so
um but anyways i just wanted to uh
make that comment thank you mr chairman
thank you representative representative
baxter
i just wanted to speak to what
representative genigean just said i
i think he made a couple of great points
regardless of what you think of the r d
tax credit it doesn't really make a lot
of sense to
to have that be a part of the question
on interest and dividends tax
you're mixing personal business and and
i
agree with what he said that a lower
exemption wouldn't necessarily have a
significant
impact and even uh in
house bill uh 568
even going through that um
that schedule of raising the exemptions
we're still going to be able to keep
uh the brunt of the revenue coming in
because it's very much
top-heavy so i think it's important that
we continue to discuss this
and listen from experts and we'll you
know we'll have more
debates and discussions about what the
correct uh number is
um and whether we go with 568 or scale
it back
um but i think um i think we're we're
still the point where
all members of the committee are um you
know still thinking about um what their
position is on the issue
okay thank you representative baxter
uh representative yeah could i just
add something that i don't think
people may be thinking about which is
that a lot of the people
in that zero payment and one to 500
payment are elderly people
who are have to
file because of where the exemption is
now
and who have to find all of their income
reports which can be difficult
and take them down to the senior center
or wherever and have a volunteer
do it for them or they they feel they
may feel that
they have to pay h r block to do it for
them
which is going to cost them more money a
lot more money than what they're paying
us
and on that raising the exemption just a
little bit
believes an awful lot of those people of
the paperwork
burden and possible cost of an
accountant
thanks
thank you yeah this just commenting on
on that last uh
observation by representative alame uh
it triggered
a thought uh we have in this uh
this attacks a elderly exemption as well
and
this bill i believe raises that
along with the base exemption i assume
that i don't have it right in front of
me
but in any event there is data that the
dra has on people who are over 65
because of that exemption and it should
be
easy to access i think it'll be very
helpful to all of us
to understand the degree to which
older people 65 years ago
and over are in fact
participants in this tax and
to what degree they're benefiting from
the current exemptions to the extent to
which dra is able to provide that so i'm
just that's just sort of an added
uh part of the request to dra that i'm
requesting
okay i just want to check the attendees
melissa rollins is on
she's unmuted melissa
you've heard this discussion but do you
have anything you can add at this point
in time
sure um actually if you could unmute
devin rodrick he did the fiscal note um
for this bill and has some of the
answers to you
um specifically for the um
over 65 i think he has the counts on
thank you melissa thank you chairman
members of the committee
this is devin roderick department of
revenue um looking at tax here 2019 data
for the ind
tax um of the the um
70 437
ind returns filed
and i can send you these numbers after
oh yes please do
yep i will 37 343 returns
those exemptions totaled and i'll break
them down in a second for you
those exemptions total 53 059
so when we look at those total number
exemptions some of those returns may
claim of course more than one exemption
depending on the
qualifying factor of those 53 059
exemptions
36 360
or 65 or older or disabled
and 16471
claimed the spouse being blind 65
or older or disabled so this the spouse
exemption is all grouped together
that's based on the way our forms are
the way the taxpayer completes our forms
and the data that we have
and we can most certainly take a look at
what representative just um
asked for a few minutes ago um at those
varying
levels of the um the actual income
exemption
at levels of 2600 2800 and 3 000 we can
take a look at that and get back to the
committee
okay and you'll send that to us
and then i can make sure it gets the
committee
thank you very much any questions of the
dra
representative ames yeah thank you i i
just wanted to comment briefly on the
other half
of the bill it's this research
and development tax credit and uh say
that i do agree with taking that out
but i want to want to say that the
reason it was in there i believe this is
true
representative abrami can correct me if
i'm wrong
was that the thought of the proponents
of the bill
originally was that they wanted to
so that the revenue that would be lost
by the increased exemptions would be
balanced by revenue that would be gained
from something else and what they chose
was the research and development
piece i've always opposed the bill
actually for that reason because i
i didn't want to go with that with
removing that tax credit
um but i i i do support the gen
in general this uh
effort to present a balance
when we cut cut revenues
uh trying to show how we'll match the
cut
and sort of as a general principle if we
keep this low
enough and i think that's uh what we're
talking about here it's a relatively
small amount of money
and it's certainly uh the the need for
increasing the exemptions
is uh i think uh is very real
and relates to the fact that they
haven't been raised for years and years
and years i don't know how long it's
been
but so so that's good
um i i guess i wish we could go much
higher on the exemptions
but then we got into big money so
there's a balance here
and going up some makes sense to me
let's get a good handle on the costs and
go into it with our eyes open so that's
what i wanted to say
cherry can i respond that's just my name
was mentioned um
representative romney thank you so yeah
uh i'm trying to recall the the genesis
of all of this but
um when i was i i've been a legislation
11 years now so when i first was uh
you know let's go say 10 years ago the
tax exemption
the tax excuse me the tax credit for r d
was a million dollars that was it
and uh then we agreed a year or two
after that that maybe we house and
senate both agreed to raise it by a
million dollars
then somewhere along the line i think in
the next budget
the senate again acting on its own
uh put into hb2 that that tax credit
would
be increased by five million dollars and
in a bipartisan way
on this committee we were not happy with
that
we were not happy that they did this
without
conferring with us again once again they
just put it in there
and you know it's the magic of hp2 i
call it you know things happen in hb2
so when it i think the bill came
to us about the exemptions and i'm
guessing i can't recall exactly but
it was it was midterm it was after the
budget was set
we wanted to do this we thought it would
be higher probability of passing
if we made it budget neutral because the
budget had already been
set so we took a bill that came to us
probably the second
year of the two years and we said let's
let's pay for it
and that's where the reduction came from
uh
but i don't think it passed because it
didn't
call now but it obviously didn't go
anywhere because it's
still a seven million dollar tax credit
that's kind of the history of it
and represent me if you want to jump in
to say
correct me if i was wrong about some of
the feelings we had about
going historically i'd appreciate it i
think
um representative spillsbury was
okay next and then we'll go to represent
thank you mr chairman just very briefly
i i like um
representative olney's request to model
the increments
uh but i would ask specifically that
while dra is doing that
that they also model the increments that
are proposed in these two bills so
in 210 3500
and in 568 a progression of 4 800
fine devin did you hear that
sure thing we'll definitely include that
in our analysis okay thanks steven
representative major yes there's a a
phone
on on our panel that i don't know who it
is i don't recognize
um would you say the last two numbers
the last numbers are seven seven eight
seven seven eight hamburg shamburg
oh okay well for 35 minutes i haven't
heard anything
oh no okay yes okay i'm just listening
thank you i'm gonna rename you is that
okay
i don't care how you rename it
you got to talk to his mother first
[Laughter]
all right uh you're also represented
you're muted onsen okay thank you
uh representative ober uh yes just a
comment on the past if if you remember i
was actually on ways and means when we
went through this
rigmarole about how to give money away
to the people that do tech
and we went from one we went to two and
it was a big discussion
when we went to two million dollars
about what are we getting for our money
and the the tech companies said well
we're going to give you more people
we're going to hire people our business
is going to expand
but we never heard what actually
happened
and it moved to 7 million without our
even knowing about it
and we still don't know all those people
that are getting this
tax deferral we don't know that we're
doing anything with that money are they
hiring more people
is their business expanding are they
doing good with that money
or are they just saying hey this is free
money let's keep going at it
i got on the list of questions that need
anybody else with questions for the dra
or
i guess this is a question for the dra
because we keep
getting told by the business and
economic
uh affairs department or whatever it's
called now
all i know is the eea on that
they can't answer us because they don't
know who the people who took the credit
are and the dra is the only one who
knows who took the credit
is there some way to be
able to get more
information about on well
what concerns me most is how much our
credit is relative to what they get
from the federal government and we do
know in the case
of the uh person in
on representative ames district that
uh it's about 25 which i thought it
would be less than that
on and i've been worried that we were
just a flea on the tail of the dog
and that we were spending money with
no real impact and
and we've been asking for years for this
and
they haven't they told us that they
couldn't reply
and i'm hoping dra can figure out
some way that discussing it with bea
that they could get some responses from
some of the people
other people that have been involved
with this program
and what they actually did with the
money uh
every time we increase uh the credits
on more people sign up for it
because it's worth more worth the
paperwork to them
and the original intent was to help the
struggling businesses at the bottom
that were in research and development
and that are the future of our economy
thanks this is going to be a separate
issue
to be able to put our hands around
this whole issue of the r d tax credit
that were as a result of it
what have they done and so
we don't have a specific bill for that
refers to it in this bill so i'll put
something together
maybe i have to be an ad hoc committee
mr chairman if i could the tax
expenditure committee
was going to start trying to look at
this this year
and the senate seems to have decided to
it was in last year's one of their big
bills
i do not know who the chairman of the
tax expenditure committee that's going
representative ames didn't you get put
not to my knowledge i had recommended
you
okay i will find out
any further questions on this issue to
kind of sum up
on house bill 210 i think the vast
majority
[Music]
divorce the r d development from
the interest and dividend credits
and uh our question then
is on increments of changes from a
couple hundred dollars
increments what is that going to cost us
some people are just persistent
um
568 is increasing the exemption to the
interest and dividend tax
until eventually repealing it in 2025
it has a lot of the same arguments that
we had on
210.
so i'm open to hear
it would eventually settle down to about
110 million dollar
each year to our budget
representative southwood i thank you mr
chairman
um i'm opposed to this bill again i
think
we have too many variables going on and
i don't really see an upside to reducing
revenue
um i could give a long spiel but i think
to just say briefly
my main concern is the result will be
downshifting more costs
to property taxpayers and i guess the
two big things i see
happening in the next two years are we
don't really know what's happening with
meals and rooms tax and we also don't
know what exactly is going to happen
with public education and those are big
big things
and uh you know i'm not sure it's a time
to cut revenue
thank you and if we don't know
if the vast majority we don't know the
answers of these questions
yes mean that we need to
either retain it or i tell it
but i would i would report retention
except i don't think we're going to know
much about
covet and some of that within one year
let's hear from somebody else uh
representative brownlee followed by
representative elmer
thank you mr chair um i'm for i'm
personally not in favor of
the the uh the end point uh with the
total reduction of this tax
uh this is something we're working
through in our caucus
and uh we're working on it and that's
why i i viewed the two bills the 210 and
this together
somehow we got to combine these two and
uh
come up with a strategy that uh at least
you know that we can agree to we may not
we
may not come to a total agreement
between the caucuses
but um again i i think
eliminating 111 million dollars in a
couple of years of revenue
um that's a that's a hard one to just
follow for me
uh and i think it's a different dynamic
than the business tax cuts and uh we
could talk about that at some other time
but
um i don't think it'll work the same way
as business tax cuts
so in terms of generating more revenue
than uh
than not so that's that's where i
personally stand on it and uh
we'll be working in our caucus uh to
come up with some some kind of a
strategy here thank you
representative alamed
thank you on this is 225 million
a year uh a biennium for our biennial
budget
it is a very significant amount of money
on we don't know
can you hear me yeah would you say 225
million
on per biennium it's 225
and on we don't know where that would
come from
we wouldn't maybe we could we would
would have to cut
on the community colleges and training
programs on which our economy depends
maybe we would have to we would
certainly be
given the way people have been in the
past be cutting out the substance abuse
programs that our businesses depend on
at least in my community the business
businesses sure depend on it
um and on there
are the the courts would suffer
we would have longer waits in the courts
the courts are
already heavily backed up
before covid they were heavily backed up
there's a whole range of government
services
that both our families and our
our businesses depend on
we cannot in this then the modern age
run a government with no i mean run a
state
have a state or a nation
without a government anarchy is not
an option so i really
[Music]
am totally opposed to
further cuts in an already very closely
budgeted
state thank you thank you representative
time table yeah
i'm sorry i was slow to get to the
unmute button
there but i just wanted to point out
if you look at dra's annual report
you'll see that
that we first had uh tax on interest and
yes okay am i back on board
yes gotta watch out for this cursor
so this is a long-standing uh tax and
it began in 1923
and according to the dra annual report
it was in 1964
i think they make there's a typo here
um could have been 75
when the rate of 5 was settled upon
so it's been at that 5 rate
at least since 1975
[Music]
and it's as a steady
part of our revenue structure i see no
reason to to change that
now and i hope will take i i hope that
we'll reject
uh that part of the bill thank you
thank you representative ames uh
mr chairman a very quick question does
anyone know
i just set it open the lba
report should tell you that
uh how about devin or melissa
would you know the answer to that thank
you chairman members with me this is
devin roderick department of revenue
going off of that annual our annual
report from fiscal year 2020
that representative ames was mentioning
a minute ago the um
exemption was increased to 1200 in
1981 and then
the threshold was increased to
um twenty four hundred dollars um
shortly thereafter so
the effective date of that was
you're saying that the 2400 has been in
i wasn't around them but i believe based
on my interpretation i believe so yes
um
do you have any further questions
represent bernstein thank you thank you
mr chair
just to to layer add a layer onto
representative spillsbury's
last comments if you go to the
us bureau of labor statistics they have
a cpi
calculator now um and if you plug in a
exemption from july of 1981
that would be equivalent to a 6800
it would be equivalent to over 6 800
today
so if the intent of this tax was to
capture a certain
um economic
tier then we haven't
adjusted this for inflation and um just
the bottom line is
2400 in 1981 is equal to 6850
today i'll just ask you to consider that
thank you uh
representative elmi
thank you this is why uh this tax is
very difficult
for my caucus when the interest and
dividends tax was created
somewhere around 1913 uh or 17
on it was meant to tax the people
who were fairly wealthy
because they were the only ones with
dividends
and interest in the bank on
and it has over time as things have
changed it has come
to to uh
a large number of people that
really uh don't
don't have very much money to live on
but it is also a
significant part of our tax structure
and does tax on
a lot of people who have a huge amount
of money to live on
in their old age so
it's a very difficult issue i agree
but we would have to find a replacement
for the revenue
or it would go on the local property tax
for as part of it and another part of it
would be services disappearing
that both the businesses and the
citizens need
representative tucker uh yes i had
um a concern when
uh members of both caucuses have been
talking about
dealing with this issue within their
caucus because
i think this issue
is one that we we need to hear each
other's views
as just this conversation has been going
on
we've learned new facts about how long
exemption have been in place how long
the tax has been in place
both caucuses to be able to individual
members
to be able to raise questions and
concerns
i think it's a really difficult issue
and
we all need to hear each other i hope
this is what we're doing right now
yes i think we are
um
representative bromley followed by
representatives
my comment about our caucus still
working together on this is
i i'm assuming you're doing the same on
it's just so that we can come to some
kind of a consensus among ourselves
to pose to the larger group here uh and
i'm sure all of the
all of the comments are gonna come out
eventually i'm sure we're gonna have
another discussion on this
this bill uh in another work session and
uh i'll just leave it at that yes we're
for open discussion no question
and i think we may want to open it up
we'll have it we'll have a full
discussion right now but
uh but i'll leave it at that thank you
representative thank you mr chair
um my comments are in response to
representative almi's
um recent comments and i i hope i can
say this without sounding snarky or
disrespectful because i
i truly admire representative army and
um she brings a lot to the table and i
know how hard she's worked for the
i i love you but it seems like
reducing government resources is totally
off the table
in your opinion you know this pandemic
has caused
every household in new hampshire to
scale back
and live within its means this pandemic
has asked every business in new
hampshire to do the same thing to make
tremendous sacrifices
i i don't see where it should be off the
table to ask the government to cut back
as as well so i'm i'm not saying
um i'm just saying that that should be
in the
array of possibilities that perhaps
since we've asked
every household and every business to
scale back a little bit to tighten their
belt to sacrifice
but it's not out of the question it's
not beyond the pale
to ask the state government to do the
same thing
that sounded pretty respectful didn't it
that's all right
thank you could i reply
represent railway thank you on
i think we're looking at different sides
of the problem on and
the side that i'm trying that
i and the i think the others in my
caucus are trying to look at
is that the government is not
providing services that
are unneeded and the people
that benefit from those services are
the same people that you're trying to
get
more money to by cutting the resources
it's it's because we do
budget so closely in this state
on and we we frequently don't invest
enough in the future because it would
cost money now
to be able to make things more efficient
in the future but we also
cut out services and i've seen many
services
cut out in my 25 years since i came home
and joined the legislature on
we cut out services that make things
harder
for the families that make things harder
for for the employees of businesses and
that make things harder for the
businesses
themselves because there is so much
within our budget
that is mandated either by our
constitution
or by the federal government or
or just by the fact that the citizens
have had this for a long time
and they they get really upset when it
disappears
and that's why a lot of it a lot of
those services when you cut them out at
the state level
shift down to the towns and have to be
paid for there or they're going to lose
them
that's sorry that's being respectful
back i really appreciate your
your intelligence and thought to these
things
representative murphy thank you chairman
um i just want to you know
i'm trying to synthesize representative
bernstein's opinion
versus uh representative all me
and as i look at it i don't look at it
as
the democrats simply wanting to
you know spend money unnecessarily nor
the republicans solely wanting to cut
all taxes
there is a middle ground when you live
in new hampshire
for as many years as i have over five
decades and have taken care of people in
the state for over
four decades you come to realize
that the services we're providing at the
state level are
significant and even not enough at this
point and beyond
school and education which we all
discuss
i was listening to west central last
night
in the state we have the third highest
overdose rate in the country
we have uh
the number we're the number one state in
alcohol consumption
as a result of that there is right now
one in five people in this state
suffer from anxiety or depression so
what i'm getting at is that the services
that we provide
are mental health which is under duress
right now
in the emergency room last year we were
down to zero
patients being housed in the emergency
room that has
gone way back up again it's very
stressful for hospitals
because we because you have to take care
of the emergency room it's stressful for
physicians and nurses
it's stressful for other patients there
as well so
i'm saying that a lot of the services
are things like mental health
which we are not funding adequately
medicaid
we have which is uh as you know a
combined
federal and state program we provide
43 less revenues for medicaid than does
our neighboring state in vermont um
and so what i'm really arguing for is
that not for
simply just cut taxes or simply
overspend
the taxpayer money i would like to think
of ourselves
as fiscally responsible but socially
aware
of the problems in the state and we have
significant social issues and i'm just
saying that
we can only gut our revenue sources so
much before people
suffer and you see it day and night food
insecurity in this state right now is
going through the roof
our unemployment rate is is twice what
it was before the pandemic so
i'm just trying to shed an overarching
view of
maybe a middle ground that we need to
take with respect to
taxes versus you know spending so thank
you
thank you representative murphy
representative
malloy uh thank you very much uh mr
chairman uh
and thank you uh representative murphy
for that comment uh this
uh uh i was in an unrelated meeting
to in another meeting last night where i
learned
just about this mental health situation
that you're talking about um and the
emergency room situation i also found
out
in that meeting that we're sending kids
down to anna jack's hospital
because we can't do it here where
there's it's over it's overflowing
and they're they're hanging out in
emergency rooms with these
these same kinds of things so um
what i'm what i what i want to use here
is a response to representative
bernstein
to say that there's a cost here
a societal cost an infrastructure cost
and i think this is still and i can i
think this all goes to
what kind of a state we are and do
people look at us
as a place to do business as a place to
come to as a place to raise their family
as a place
that we're going to take care of our own
and um
and earlier another testimony i talked
about how this trickles down to
towns and property taxpayers and it does
and i wasn't talking about building a
new school
uh with raising uh that money this is
about
being able to keep and hire good
policemen
keeping higher good firefighters keeping
higher good teachers
based upon the backs of the property
taxpayers
so uh that's where that's my position
and i believe that all of this goes to
who we are and what we define as a as a
quality
place to live and encourage people to
grow their families here
end of conversation thank you thank you
mr
representative
we're going to have to break the apple
and make a decision on
210 568.
once you seriously consider we need to
get it out by march 11th
looks like we may not get it out this
week
uh but we'll see how things progress
now tomorrow we have public hearings on
so many bills what i was planning on is
that
some of those bills aren't very long
especially the ones in the morning
that we could take some time in between
the bills
to at least exact
a coup a few of these bills that we
talked about today
if the amendment on 3 30
and 306 is ready that would be a big
help
for those that we don't exec
tomorrow will have another bite of the
apple
when we have public hearings again which
would be
on the 18th we're going to have to meet
with
the governor's budget director and go
revenues on the 23rd like to get the
draft
numbers out of the revenue so we can
send these numbers over to finance
with or without an hr and that's what
that's essentially and then that's the
23rd there isn't much time left between
the 11th but we have
all of these bills that we talked about
today
we have i think seven new bills just
here
on the 17th
and then we'll pop we'll be getting
bills
after they have the session on the 24th
and the 25th
those bills that the policy committees
have
passed and they pass the
session they deal with revenues look at
getting those bills
that's essentially where we stand at
this point in time so
i think we've done a great job this
morning here it is just 12
after 12. we've gone through an awful
lot
thank everybody for participating
we still have a few more people that we
need to
get them going because you know the only
way this
works is everybody contributes their
uh when do you want those who made the
motions to get you
their uh report
you can get me the report by the end of
the weight
okay just wanted i wanted i just want to
make sure everybody knew that okay thank
you
we'll have time to get them out i i
would like to have
one you know we the action was taken now
and those motions should be written up
now
yesterday we uh when we were doing the
revenues um
we we were talking about the tobacco
attacks in the mess in massachusetts
um i did ask jennifer still on the on
the call here
i did ask jennifer to research what's
going on in
massachusetts so hopefully she'll have
something for us by next
next week in terms of any legislation i
guess there's a senate bill that's
active
but she's going to research as much as
you can before next week for us
was jennifer on yeah she was but she had
to take a break
he's been monitoring you go to another
room that's what i should
he's monitoring a couple of uh we'll get
that later then
she's gonna she's going to report to us
next week
okay anything else from any of the
committee members
if not mr mr chairman yes representative
i just wanted to let the new members
know that if you
volunteer to write a blurb the chairman
on
can work with you to make sure that
absolutely
and uh i already have one board but
we've got to sit down with somebody
and discuss it because the verb
should clearly state what the bill does
and if there's amendment you have to
explain the amendment
and then also explain
why the committee is doing what they do
and if it costs money how much yes
or racism the effect
and if you have any problems you can
always start by looking at
last year's verbs
and you'll find one that covers this
subject similar to what you have and it
gives you an idea because
by the time the burp gets into the
calendar it's reviewed by
the chairman
and then the clerks and then it goes to
the house court and house court
may make changes and you won't know that
until it comes out
in print and then
and we want that to reflect
our committee doing their job there's
nothing worse than
reading somebody's board and uh
we passed this committee want to pass a
all right have a good lunch
hey edie hi
wonderful john jen to tell her we're all
done
well so we're coming back after lunch
no i didn't think so
it's sunny out so maybe it's warmer i
can go for a walk
yeah it looks beautiful it made me
nervous
when uh representative romney said
they'd discuss this in caucus
um yeah because that's a really
you know there are lots of people in the
north country who are in my position
although i'm
relatively fortunate economically but
that is that
they're widows and they're paying
interest and dividends tax on they have
social security
which is less when they're just one
survivor and you know
that group that particular tier is
really hard hit by that
and i understand that the state counts
on that revenue
but you know and it's going to be worse
and worse
as more and more people don't have
pensions
or they're getting distributions for a
401k
and i assume when they talk about
distributions we've never really
established that
but is that what they're talking about
i don't know i found that confusing but
i was looking through some of our tax
documents and
i saw that word in there distributions
and
try and figure out you know what it is
specifically well this year the
the feds said you didn't need to take a
minimum required distribution
if you had ira or a 401k
but most people did because in fact
that's that's the income they're living
on plus social security i mean they're
not
yeah only wealthy people should come
over
and that shouldn't come under interest
and dividends should it
i i think we ought to ask whether that's
a distribution or not
i don't know yeah but i mean if we're
going to fiddle around with it
we need to understand it better right
because i think that with
the world of pensions disappearing
and certainly up here you know most of
the people who worked at the mail who
expected
get a pension right they never got it
because the guy on the paper mill
was a crook and
you know he's still in jail i think in
any case they never got their pensions
so people who built a life of
really hard work and a lot of those jobs
were
i would consider really hard work
working at the pulp mill but we probably
should tell
tom lochmann we're all done for the day
okay good to know thank you i got
disconnected i had a connectivity issue
where it was
i was trying to promote you from